- West Palm Beach is just a
place that hits home to me.
It's where it all started.
I remember when I was just goin’ in,
just hoop, tryna have fun.
And you were just young. You have
a dream, and it's just, like, you're just
trying to achieve whatever you can do.
So you just went outside late at night,
going to the park, tryna go hoop, tryna go grind.
- If I could start with this acai bowl.
- Yeah, you know, I’m eating healthy now.
- Yeah.
- Come on, I’m trying to get big. Stay in shape.
The acai bowl. As you can see, the
strawberries with bananas.
I think that’s oats. And you got a little bit of
honey in it. It’s fire, you know.
It’s been my go-to.
It's pretty good though.
No cap.
Look at that. Come on, get a
good look at that.
Growing up, my mom raised me by
herself, and she always tried to do
stuff for me and my two brothers and
one sister. To see how hard she works,
that pushes me.
You just wanna help your family out,
give back to them,
cuz they put so much
time and effort into you.
If you was to ask me what my dream is, I just,
as a kid, you know, you always had to have a dream
I just grew up watching basketball.
So it's always been a dream of mine.
One of my proudest achievements
was winning my first gold medal,
U16.
I feel like it opened up a lot for me.
It was me, James Wiseman, Vernon
Carey, Jalen Green, Jalen Suggs.
I never expected that in my life.
So it was just crazy to me.
People started looking at me more.
Started blowin’ up after that.
- [Announcer:] Here’s Barnes now.
Down the lane, and it goes.
- [Announcer:] And he just is so long.
Elongates to the rim there in
the open court.
- Jumping into that system,
I knew that was the right fit for me.
Just when I watched the program, they had
said they wanted me to do—talk to coaches.
I already knew what it was from the jump.
So that just allowed me
to go in there, be who I am.
- [Announcer:] Oh! That's what you're
talking about right there.
Scottie Barnes.
- During the season, it
was, I would say it was very different.
Plenty of teammates getting COVID, and then you
gotta sit out two weeks.
Can't play a game.
That was very weird, you know? It's
just like you always on your toes.
- Scottie first came out to Santa Barbara, and we
got in the gym to kinda evaluate his
game and where he's at. The first thing,
you know, we had done ahead of time
was go over film and kind of prepare
for him, and his ability to be, you
know, a big point forward and be able
to just create for everybody else
is so obvious.
- I’m just trying to make the right
play each and every time.
So if play’s open, I'm trying
to find that play and see what’s the right
decision to make.
- [Trner:] The big thing we wanted
to really work on, you know, further developing
his jump shot and his confidence in it.
He’s just such a pass-first guy
that it’s getting him to understand,
like, sometimes the best option is
him taking that shot.
Full extension,
full extension, full extension.
Yes, sir.
- I like Packie.
Cool, fun dude.
- Nice guy to talk to as well.
- [Barnes:] Taught me a lot about my shot.
Helped me get my general feeling
from where I’m starting from
to where I’m goin’
just helps me get better.
- [Turner:] Setting a number
for him or giving him, “Hey, we're
trying to go five out of seven” or
“three for five” or “seven out of 10,”
you know, it’s just giving him a goal.
He's a competitor.
So he always rises to the occasion
and wants to go until he can get it.
- Let's go. Look at the boys.
Look at them boys.
P3 boys right there.
- Those are P3 boys right there?
- Look at them.
[Honking horn]
Hey, guys!
So we at P3 right now.
We about to get the arms, shoulders
right.
Think it's arm day.
So we ‘bout to hit it. ‘Bout to
meet the crew.
- I mean, the idea behind
P3 was that we could
collect more data on athletes.
We could have them have this interaction
with technology that would give us
information about how these guys
move, how their bodies work, how
their systems are put together
so we can take better care of them.
And so when we assess an athlete like
Scottie Barnes, we can compare his system
to all the physical systems that he's
gonna be competing against in the NBA.
- [Barnes:] Developed my muscles
at P3.
And now we’ve just been training and
working on different things.
Helping me jump better. Not doing so
much to try to get us all big and strong,
but just to maintain and make us feel good.
That’s why I like it.
I feel like after P3, you could
just go hoop on the court.
They keep us right.
- We’ve had Scottie for three years now.
Pretty much all of these top
young players find their way to P3
before they get to the NBA now.
And so we can track their—not
just their—how their physical
system looks at one point in time,
but we can track their development cycle.
Scottie is a really good athlete.
These last two years,
he's made huge gains.
Like, much steeper growth
curve than most of our young athletes.
And this time when we assessed him, his
drop vertical was the second-highest
we'd ever measured, with comps from
almost 900 NBA players that we've
assessed. The second-highest jump ever.
Like, that's—it was phenomenal.
- Scott,
I’ll give you five bucks if you eat that one.
- Bro, I don’t even know what that is.
- I’ll give you 10.
- I don’t know what that is, though.
- Twenty.
- What is that?
- Twenty. $20.
I'll give you $20. I’m not
about to feed you!
- No, I wanna smell it.
Bro, that smells terrible. What the heck?
- Bro, I’ll give you 20. I’ll give you $20.
- I might throw up if I eat that.
- I’ll give you $20 if you can eat this.
- I can’t.
I'm bad at trying new foods.
Greg’s like family.
We like cousins, to be honest.
We lit, though.
He my hype man, I’m his hype man.
He’s lit. I like Greg.
Let’s go! Good defense, KD!
There was four people guarding this man
when he tried to bring it up in transition.
Come on, man.
That's how you know he’s like that.
Bro, go set
a double-down screen for KD.
That’s a tough guard.
- Tough cover. Very tough cover.
- I’d rather guard Giannis than KD.
- Yeah.
- Bruh, just give it to KD.
Oh!
Oh, y'all ahead.
- [Offscreen:] Oh, I’m sorry.
- Wait, what?
- Oh, they ahead of us.
Come on. What we on, what we on?
He made that.
- That’s game.
- That’s a wrap.
- Man, Santa Barbara. Man, the beach—sunset.
It’s nice out
here, baby. Livin’ life.
Me, I just want to win games. If
I need to
play power forward, help my team get
rebounds, push the transition,
that's what I do.
If I need the ball in my hands
to create, look for open people, get
shooters involved, things like that,
be a slasher—
whatever's needed,
that's what I'm willing to do
to try to win basketball games.
- I see Scottie’s role in the
NBA evolving really right on
point with the times, right?
He's positionless, so Scottie really fits
with today's NBA and the ability to be
anywhere and everywhere at the same time.
- If you take a guy that has the work
ethic that Scottie has and you give
him the right blueprint to get better,
then, you know, he's gonna just
keep going.
- Whatever fanbase it is,
you know, I'm just gonna
come in working hard from day one..
I'mma come in with the
right mindset, right approach.
I feel like it's gonna be a good vibe,
you know? I'mma have fun.
They gonna have fun in the crowd.
It's gonna be a perfect combination.
Of course it’ll be
a pretty special moment.
It's gonna be one of the biggest
moments of my life, everything that I've been
working for. I don’t know if I’ll cry.
I’m probably gonna scream.
“Ahhh, let’s go!”
Still got a long way to go.
It ain’t over yet. I feel like it’s
just one step. A big part of you
getting there, but you gotta do things
to stay there.
You can't just get there
and then think it's over.
You got way more of the
journey that we've got to go.
I just wanna leave that legacy that
Scottie Barnes was one of those
guys that was just a different
type of guy that studied the game,
that I did whatever I could.